metro police are pulling back the
curtain for the first time on a problem
they say
is plaguing the las vegas valley
unlicensed
group homes vanessa murphy is here with
an exclusive look
on what investigators have found a rest
they've made
and how prevalent the problem may be
here vanessa denise and bryan metro
police tell us they've discovered
36 unlicensed group homes over the past
two years
licensed group homes have strict rules
they have to follow some
offer specialized care but in unlicensed
homes police say the elderly the
homeless
and people with disabilities are
recruited ripped off
and placed in dangerous living
conditions
these operators they don't really see
what we see
the victims they see them as cash cows
police say they discovered 18
elderly and vulnerable adults along with
two children
living in this six bedroom east side
home in 2019.
investigators described the conditions
as deplorable
they say mary glenn was in charge court
records obtained by the i-team reveal
she's a felon with
aliases she was one of the most
egregious that we've had
metro sergeant james johnson says there
may be hundreds of victims since glenn
operated several
unlicensed group homes prosecutors say
she had no license to run a business or
provide medical care
lieutenant david valente says police are
uncovering
more of these types of unlicensed group
homes throughout clark county
these are people that are looking for a
roof over their head
they're being targeted because they have
steady governmental benefits social
security
medicaid and they're taking advantage of
them putting them in a house
and then not delivering on the promises
they gave them
he says the promise is for a room food
and in some cases medical care
but residents soon learn the truth no
heating
no air condition bed bugs infestation
rodents no running water no working
bathrooms where they'll stack
10 15 20 people in and remember these
people
all need a higher level of care than you
or i sergeant johnson says residents in
some homes may not even have access to
their own money
some victims with dementia may not
understand how they got there
in some homes there are individuals
known as enforcers
they're anointed to be the caretaker but
realistically
they're there to make sure nobody causes
waves nobody notifies authorities calls
the police
so they can just keep the the cash flow
going investigators say glenn and her
partner devin floyd told police they
made about
30 thousand dollars each month in mostly
cash rent
from various group homes they ran in the
valley the arrest report describes some
of the victims
found in this home a 75-year-old with
parkinson's
lying in his own urine who said he was
fed once a day
a 66 year old with dementia who cried he
needed his medications
and his 75 year old double amputee who
had to leave the house to use the
restroom
since the first floor bathroom didn't
work after police went in with a search
warrant
some of the residents were taken to the
hospital the two children were placed
with child protective services
glenn and floyd face charges related to
abuse and
neglect of the elderly and the
vulnerable both are in jail awaiting
trial
as investigators continue to find more
unlicensed
group homes it's sad it really is sad
what
somebody will do to somebody else just
to make a few dollars
prosecutors say while mary glenn was
placed on house arrest
she fraudulently filed for unemployment
and small
business loans and she received
approximately
30 thousand dollars she faces additional
charges now and as i mentioned earlier
she's back in jail no comment from the
attorneys for glenn and floyd